[Music]
so hi my name's ace I'm a developer
programs engineer here at Google cloud
and today we're going to be talking
about releasing with confidence so
testing debugging and monitoring any
service world so our agenda for today
first off we're going to talk about
testing what it is how we do it why we
do it just kind of as an explanation of
the context of this slide or this
presentation then we're going to take
that knowledge and wrap it up in the
world of functions as a service third
we're going to talk about how to
automate this process using a CI CD or
continuous integration and deployment
platforms and fourth we're gonna talk a
little bit about the operations of
functions so first a quick background on
testing testing can be defined as sort
of two separate things so we're asking
two high-level questions here first of
all does our code work in the first
place and second of all does our code
work well so lower level questions we
can ask under this heading include but
are not limited to does our code work
with style and language guidelines those
are code work with our its latest
dependencies does our code work when
subjected to extreme loads or perhaps
even does our code work when provided
malicious or otherwise invalid input so
along this there's a broad spectrum of
tests we can rely on to help us answer
the question of whether or not our code
works at all so off to the left you'll
notice we have unit tests which
generally speaking are faster and more
specific off to the right we have system
tests which are slower and more
comprehensive and then in the middle we
have integration tests which are kind of
a hybrid of the two so generally
speaking the goal of this presentation
is to get to you to a point where you
can figure out whether or not your code
works at all we are less concerned about
figuring out why it does not work
although that is something I will get to
later so along those lines the system
tests are typically more essential for
determining whether or not
your code works at all now unit tests
can be helpful when it comes time to
determine why your code doesn't work
because they give you greater
granularity of what the failures are and
what things are going wrong so as a
rough indication of how many test types
how many types of each test you need on
the bottom of the slide we have a rough
diagram so imagine that you have a
feature right and this feature is tested
by one system test so if you were to
cover that feature completely with
integration tests you might need 2
integration tests or perhaps even up to
4 unit tests to cover that feature
completely note that these ratios are
not exact
they are simply an example so the second
high-level aspect of testing that we can
inter investigate is not only does our
code work but does it work well so
static tests are a type of test that
tests your code for things such as style
without actually running the code all
the other tests we will talk about today
involve actually running a part of your
code so load testing this is a type of
system test that directly measures your
codes ability to handle either expected
or unexpected loads basically you throw
a bunch of traffic at it and see if it
can handle the punishment and then fuzz
tests and vulnerability scanners test
your codes ability to handle malicious
input so if people try to hack your
application or things like that
so as far as why we test so testing can
be thought of as an insurance policy
against potential bugs and their
associated business impact so if you
ever need to justify the management well
why should we write tests it's not so
much they prevent bugs as much as it is
they prevent bugs which might have a
business impact on our bottom line so
the first goal of testing is to reduce
the likelihood of software errors
happening in the first place the second
is to verify code correctness on an
ongoing basis if you wanted to manually
test your code once or twice that's easy
enough to do the problem comes when you
want to test it say every week or every
day after a while the costs spent
manually testing is greater than the
cost of just automating it and then
running an automated test suite each
time you want to test
so the stretch goal here is to quickly
identify the arrows caught by any test
that we have it's not strictly necessary
but it would be helpful in the debugging
process so as far as the impact of
testing Google's OSS fuzz fuzzing
project found more than 250 potential
security vulnerabilities in major open
source software within its first five
months of execution and inadequate
software testing has been estimated
across the United States up to 1% of its
annual GDP alone and here are the
citations for those stats so now that
we've talked a little bit about testing
as a concept we're going to move on to
applying that to the world of functions
as a service so first off as kind of a
recap about unit tests the core idea of
a unit test is to verify that the
minutiae a or the individual units of
your code work as expected so things
like educating now in the unit test
there is no reliance or verification of
extra no reliance on excuse me or
verification of external dependencies
such as libraries api's or even outright
cloud platforms but to get around this
we use mocking frameworks to fake those
external dependencies so in general unit
tests are useful for investigating known
problems and things like regressions and
whatnot however they are not as good at
finding unanticipated problems that you
know kind of come out of left field but
they are fast to run and rarely use
build resources
so typically because they're
self-contained you don't have to use any
actual cloud resources to run them so
they're almost cheap or free to run and
before we leave this slide there's a
diagram on the bottom right hand
basically you'd normally this explains
how the mocking concept works so
normally you'd have a feature right and
that feature calls an API the API
returns a response and the feature does
something with that response the marking
framework allows you to completely cut
the API out of the conversation and say
I'm going to return a predefined
response to the feature and I'm going to
assert that the feature behaves in the
way that I think it should if the API
had actually returned that response
the feature that's the core idea of unit
testing so here we have a sample HTTP
Google Cloud function this is a pretty
straightforward function that
essentially creates a creates a bucket
when given a name parameters through a
post request so it will take this post
request it will attempt to create the
bucket eat online for using the storage
that create bucket function if that
process fails it will send back an error
with the error message if it succeeds
it'll send back a success message so
here's a sample HTTP unit test you'll
notice that on line one we import a
bunch of different libraries so walking
through them proxy choir is a really
interesting library that in nodejs lets
us sort of hook into or mock a a client
library right or rather a node client
library so in this case we have this
Google Cloud Storage client library and
we're replacing it we're hooking it over
with a GCS mock object which we define
online to now that GCS mock object is a
sort of subset of that of that library
and we define a create bucket function
there that we want to receive any calls
to storage create bucket in our actual
code so instead of saying something like
we're going to actually import the real
library we import this fake version of
it this mock version of it that we
declared online to so once we do that we
can rely on the library called sign-on
which gives us lots of useful helpers to
log what kinds of arguments are being
passed to functions so you'll notice on
line two we declare something called a
stub so sign on stub and the thing about
that is that will log any arguments that
are passed to it it will log how many
times it's called things like that and
then we can inspect that stub to figure
out okay well how did the program that
we passed this stub to actually use that
stub so then we move down to our test on
line six notice that here we attempt to
create a bucket we do not actually
create a bucket so on line seven we
declare our bucket name lines eight and
nine we declare our mock versions of
and response parameters if you've worked
with cloud functions before you'll
notice that or seen the code previously
you'll notice that our function took
those parameters request and response so
we have to mock or fake them and pass
them into our program so once we do that
we then do we then run our run our code
or our original function sorry on line
10 using the program create bucket call
there and we pass that fake request and
a response object into our program just
as if it had been running on college
functions and received the real version
of those objects and then on line 11 we
check that the create bucket function or
gather our fake create bucket function
was called with the correct argument in
this case the the name constant so
moving on to integration tests the core
idea here is to verify that you the
various parts of your code fit together
as expected so integration tests broadly
speaking can either use mocking or rely
directly on external dependencies now
external dependencies that they do rely
on are usually fast and/or cheap to
access thus keeping the individual test
runs moderately fast moderately quick
but note that if you're depending on
actually build resources you would have
to pay for those invocations you would
have to pay for those runs so this may
require small amounts of money to run
each iteration of your tests but
generally speaking the day balance
problem detection and isolation and this
is the cool part about integration test
is that in some cases they can detect
unanticipated bugs
whereas unit tests can only detect
things that you really specifically
check for integration tests have a large
enough scope that if there's some bug
that happens that you haven't thought to
check for there's a better probability
that integration tests will catch it and
just as a rough sort of visual analogue
here where an integration test comes in
as let's say you have two or more
features an integration test tests their
ability to sort of operate between each
other so if you have three features you
want to see how will they they talk to
each other that's when an integration
test will come in
and here is a sample HTTP integration
test you'll notice again we import a
bunch of libraries here some of which
are the same some of which are not ava
is our testing harness so that's just a
testing framework in node UUID is a
universal unique identifier library I'll
get to why that's important later and
then request promise native is a library
that allows us to make HTTP requests in
node so notice on line - we have a
standard node require call so we are
importing a live version of the Google
Cloud storage library this this library
we are not mocking this dependency we're
importing it as is now on line four we
attempt to create a real bucket and we
do this by first declaring a bunch of
values in this case we have to declare a
name for the bucket note that we use
that UUID library that i mentioned
earlier because we want to ensure that
our bucket names are unique whenever
we're trying to create any actual cloud
resources if we don't it's possible that
we end up into some you know race
condition or something like that where
we try to create a bucket that already
exists or we try to delete one that
doesn't exist things like that so to
avoid that we use that UUID function
there now once we do that we can declare
the URL of the function we want to
attempt to send this request to in this
case it's going to be a local URL so you
know this base URL environment variable
is probably going to be something like
localhost or whatever and then on line
seven we execute that HTTP request we
say okay here's what target URL let's
pass the name to it so on and so forth
note that even when that request returns
the bucket itself may not have yet been
created so to avoid that we have to kind
of either use exponential back-off which
the idea of exponential back-off is you
wait a certain amount of time then you
wait that amount of time times to that
amount of time times four so on and so
forth constantly multiplying by some
constant or perhaps even adding some
random jitter so that if you're doing a
bunch of exponential back-off operations
they don't sort of all fall together um
but in this case it's easy and simple
enough to implement a constant delay and
that's exactly what we do on line 8
so we say we're going to wait one second
between requesting that the bucket be
created and actually checking if it
exists because the the bucket creation
API is eventually consistent like a lot
of Claude api's so we do that on line 10
we check that the the bucket exists and
if it does then our test passes if it
doesn't then well our function didn't do
what we wanted it to do and our test
fails so moving on to system tests and
kind of has a recap note that system
tests are all about verifying your code
as a system there's heavy reliance here
on external dependencies which can slow
down the test itself and sometimes
system tests will require moderate
amounts of build resources because
you're directing traffic at an actual
cloud instance now system tests have
pretty good bug detection even if bugs
are unexpected or outside your code base
this is where they really sort of show
their true power if you're trying to
figure out do I have a bug in my
dependencies or is there a bug you know
perhaps in some configuration in my
cloud platform that's where system tests
will hunt for that sort of thing
integration tests might find it unit
tests probably won't find it
but system tests have a good chance of
finding those types of bugs but note
that they are bad at isolating problems
generally speaking and their causes just
because system tests have such a large
scope that they test one thing to take
away and we discuss this in the
integration tests sample as well is that
state matters and it may introduce
either eventual consistency and/or
shared resource issues and what I mean
by shared resource issues is if you're
trying to create a resource that already
exists or you're trying to delete a
resource that doesn't exist say maybe
you're running two tests at the same
time and they both create and delete the
same test bucket then it's possible that
that will introduce like race conditions
or things like that that make your test
results essentially flaky so here's a
sample HTTP system test some of you
might notice that this looks familiar
in fact it's exactly the same as the
integration test we just discussed the
only difference is the base URL that we
specified so instead of being something
on our local machine or on you know
perhaps a local machine on the network
it's going to be the actual deployed
cloud function URL so it's going to be
like something like US central won some
region - your project ID at cloud
functions done that now the thing to
bear in mind here is the challenges of
you know those unique test runs that
state dependence and the asynchronous
nature of creating that bucket still
apply so the those are more common in
terms of system tests sometimes they
happen in integration tests sometimes
you can mock those dependencies out but
in system tests they're almost
guaranteed to happen if you're working
with a cloud platform and the one caveat
that I want to make sure I get to today
is this system test being the same as
the integration test this is a trope you
can typically exploit when you're
dealing with HTTP triggered functions if
you're dealing with something like a
pub/sub triggered function or a firebase
triggered function or something like
that it's a lot harder to just do this
and simply say my integration test and
system tests are going to be identical
so moving on a static testing so as a
recap the goal of static testing is to
verify that your code follows typically
either language and style conventions or
dependency management best practices now
many of these static testing tools are
free to install and quick to use so
there are two types of static testing
tools that I want to make sure we talk
about today the first of which is
linters and lenders are really useful
because they enforce style conventions
on your code and sometimes they can also
detect things like you know
interpretation or compilation errors so
for example for node there's a linter
linty tool called prettier there's also
a couple different other tools like es
lint or semi standard that you might
have heard of if you're Python developer
you probably know about PI lint or flake
eight or pepé or something like that and
then dependency management tools
essentially check for issues with your
dependencies so in node we have this
tool called sneak which effectively
checks for known insecure versions of
our dependencies anywhere in our
dependency tree so let's say you depend
on a package that depends on a package
that is insecure sneek will detect that
and send you an alert if you've set it
up to do so
so the major con of static testing is
that they have a very narrow focus
they're very good at doing what they do
but they do only do a very small amount
of things and and as an example of why
linting is useful you'll notice the code
on the left is basically some JavaScript
some contrived JavaScript but it's prior
to linting and then on the right we have
that code after we fix the appropriate
linting errors so on the Left basically
the big issue here is if you're not
immediately familiar with the details of
JavaScript it might not be obvious what
the value of a is now someone who is
like even me who even a person like me
who's worked with JavaScript for quite a
while might think Oh a is null just
looking at that code but in fact when
you run it
I found out even that a is undefined so
declaring it on a supper line on the
right makes it easier for other
programmers to understand now the other
thing that the linter flagged on our
left sample is that we have a double
equal sign there now in JavaScript a
double equal sign essentially means can
I cast A to B right not necessarily are
they the same type and the same value
it's more are they the same value and
can they be casted so we go off to the
right we fix that because the lender
says did you really mean to just check
value equality or do you mean to check
type equality as well and in this
situation we meant to check type
equality so we add a third equal sign
and then we get that undefined and null
they might be the same value but they
are not the same type and therefore they
are not equal and you'll notice on the
left that console dot log statement
returns true on the right it returns
false so this can have an impact in your
code so moving on to the idea of load
testing so the idea of load testing is
to verify your entire system from end to
end including importantly the non auto
scaled components ability to handle user
demand so here there's a heavy reliance
on external dependencies and these
dependencies may be slow to access which
can slow down the test runs themselves
note that a lot of load testing tools
out there are typically free
or at least open-source but the test
runs themselves can require lots of
build resources because essentially what
you're doing is creating vast amounts of
traffic and then directing it at your
app and of course you have to pay to
process that traffic but load tests
generally speaking help protect against
sudden and potentially beneficial
traffic spikes the example I like to
give is like especially if you're in
retail there are certain seasons of the
year like here in the US it's probably
like Black Friday where retail just
suddenly has a glut of customers
everyone is looking to buy your product
all of a sudden right or perhaps you
know if you work at a small start-up and
suddenly you know your your product gets
featured on a major internet news site
or a major newspaper and your user base
doubles by a factor of you know or
increases by a factor of three or four
or five so how do you test that you know
if we make it big so to speak sorry
about that if if we make it big so to
speak how are we going to make sure that
our site can handle that load well
that's where you rely on something like
a load test and again those those
traffic spikes can be beneficial it need
not be like a distributed denial service
or someone trying to take down your app
and some examples of load testing tools
we have Apache bench which we're going
to demo on the next slide and that is
pre-installed on most Mac and Linux
systems so you can just type a B on a
terminal and it's there the other option
is to use Apache g-meter if you want
something that is more configurable so
without further ado we'll talk about the
demo and you'll notice here we have a
standard terminal can everybody can
anybody not see this raise your hand if
you cannot see this good so what we're
gonna do and for good measure I'll make
a little larger so we're going to run a
command here that does a load test for
us so here we're running Apache bench
and notice what we're doing here is
we're running a 50 requests total so
we're running 50 requests total with up
to 10 requests at once so concurrency of
10 to this link which is just a simple
HTTP cloud function that I've set up and
importantly if we take a look at this
here we noticed that all of our requests
succeeded and none of our requests
failed so that means that we can count
on this function to handle the amount of
load that we've tested it - there's also
lots of other sort of interesting stats
here like you can see you know request
percentiles like the median request here
took 81 milliseconds to complete the
longest request took maybe six seconds
which is probably due to something like
a cold start or something like that and
before we get going I'm going to execute
the next step and we'll get to that
later all right so moving on to security
testing so to recap the goal of security
testing is to verify your codes ability
to handle malicious input and that of
your dependencies as well equally
importantly so the motivation for
security testing is that US business has
lost 67 billion with ABI to cyberattacks
in 2005 that was more than 10 years ago
so security tests can occur anywhere in
your testing stack they can be part of
unit test system test integration test
and/or static tests now security testing
tools are sometimes for you to install
they're often free to install they're
something you can you can purchase but
they may cost money if build resources
are involved like if you're testing your
actual cloud deployment and you have to
pay for that traffic they send you know
potentially malicious traffic to your
cloud deployment you have to pay for
that traffic so some examples of
security testing tools there's the open
web application security project which
is a great resource if you're working on
like web applications and they have
something called the Z attack proxy or
zap and that is an automated testing
tool that will go through your website
and attempt to find security
vulnerabilities in your app so then
there's sneak which I mentioned earlier
it checks for known insecure
dependencies the big list of knotty
strings essentially it's a list of
strings that could potentially break
your app so things like sequel injection
or Unicode errors or things like that
and then you have the OSS fuzz tool that
I mentioned earlier which is written by
Google
and a couple of caveats to bear in mind
with security testing if you take away
nothing it from this slide this is
probably the most important thing to to
take away so first of all no automated
tools perfect and if you're serious
about security hire consultant they will
get you closer to perfection but they
probably won't get you all the way and
then these security testing tools may
actually damage the environment that
they are pointed at some tools are
better about this than others but if a
tool say tries to drop your production
database and you point it or tries to
drop a database rather and you pointed
at your production instance and it is
successful then guess what you've
dropped your production database so when
you're dealing with security testing
tools make sure to test them in like a
test environment or or something where
you know you're either a hundred percent
confident that it is totally secure at
least from that particular security
testing tool or if it gets blown up who
cares right maybe you lose some test
data but you can either restore it from
the backup or you know it's the type of
thing your customers won't notice let me
put it that way and here's a citation
for that set I mentioned earlier so
moving on to the sort of CI CD pipeline
and talking about how to automate this
testing process so the core idea here is
that for many developers get branches
are the source of truth now if you don't
use git you probably use some sort of
version control system whether that's
Sdn or CBS or mercurial or something
like that but the core idea is you think
in terms of a version control system and
normally function code must be tested
and redeployed manually like in the
Google cloud functions context you have
to do you know your G cloud functions
deploy or you have to deploy it through
the UI UI console so to get around this
we can use continuous integration and
continuous deployment systems or
pipelines to automate that step now
there are many different CI CD options
available in the context of this
presentation we will use cloud build
primarily because it natively integrates
with Google cloud platform and source
repositories as well and in our case
github and bitbucket
so it's pretty it's actually pretty easy
to set up a basic CI cd4 cloud functions
it does take some time it does take some
configuration but you know you could
probably do it in about half a day so
here's an example build configuration
for node this file is the heart of cloud
build this essentially tells cloud build
what it needs to do to run and deploy
your code rather to run your tests and
deploy your code so if you're no
developer this will look pretty familiar
if you're not then you know we can walk
through it
but essentially what's going on here
with the first step is we're installing
our dependencies it's if you've worked
with Python this will probably look like
pip install to you now the second test
is running our tests if your group I
found developer this will look like PI
test or NOx
or something like that but if you're no
developer you use NPM test and the third
this is an optional step but if you
don't want any sort of old sort of
zombie function instances from your old
function lying around you have to go
delete it so you can do that by doing
the G cloud functions delete command now
if you would rather have those zombie
instances around and not risk
potentially deleting and not being able
to deploy your function through an
automated test it's probably better just
to deal with the zombie instances and
just nix this step but if you care more
about zombie instances then you know
potential failures on the very last step
then you probably want to include a
delete command just to get rid of the
zombie instances and then of course our
last command deploys our actual function
code and it's just a standard g-cloud
function just deploy so on and so forth
now the thing to bear in mind is this
executes from the top down so if any of
these steps fail anything below them
will not execute so if your tests fail
you will not delete or deploy the new
version of your function now if the
deletion succeeds but the deployment
fails like I said earlier you will end
up without a function deployed and if
that is bad for you if that is worse
than having some old function instances
lying around
we recommend nixing that third step
so now we're going to move to a demo of
Claude Belden but if we move to cloud
build here what we're going to do is
we're going to make a change to this
repo so we're gonna execute it now let's
first take a look at the commit logs
here so we notice that we have this
commit here that says we're going to
change hello - hi and maybe our manager
comes to us and says I don't like this
commit you need to get rid of it remove
it so we can do that using a let me
check the log again make sure I copy the
commit get reset that commit check our
status check a log get reset let's try
this soft there we go oops that failed
so let's try something else when all
else fails nuke it from orbit and then
we can push this to our master maybe
this is a prod release so we want to
make sure that we just push it as is
it's pushing now and if we take a look
at the last commit we'll notice it it's
it's this commit hash right here and we
can go to our lovely container builder
refreshment and we notice that we've
kicked off a build right here right so
if we go there we noticed this is in
response to that same git commit we just
pushed right so we can scroll down and
we get a list of these build steps here
as we define them in that cloud build
that yamo file so first we're installing
our dependencies then we're running our
tests then we're deleting our old
versions of functions notice the beta
here because this command is old and
then we are deploying our version of the
function and then if we scroll down to
our logs here we notice that the build
is starting it'll take us a second or
two to kind of get going I'm gonna zoom
out a little bit here so we can scroll
here so it's installing that's our
dependencies here it's executing step
zero that's these are just sort of NPM
prints NPM logs
then we are running our tests using NPM
we run integration tests and then we're
starting our sort of quasi emulator our
shim and trying to run our tests we
notice our tests are passing to past to
past
scrolling down so all of our tests are
starting to pass here so all of our
tests have passed well who we can now
that we can now delete our old version
of the function and we can deploy it so
as far as deleting it goes that's what
we're doing here and it's running that
deletion operation to delete the old
version of the function and then we are
deploying the function here so we've
already deployed the function and the
deployment has finished right now if we
go to this URL we'll notice that before
we had done this commit if I make this
larger this used to say hi world right
and our manager came to us and said I
don't want that I want it to say hello
world but if we refresh it now it says
hello world as our manager asked us for
so now that we talked a little bit about
how to automate that that testing
process we can talk about what to do
when you know sort of the heavens forbid
something goes wrong and a bug ends up
in production so GCF offs 101 basically
the core idea here is that tests can
only detect problems out of production
so for problems in production we're
going to need to do something different
and that something different is
stackdriver
so stackdriver is a set of tools for
monitoring and debugging code on GCP now
the most useful tools for cloud
functions in my humble opinion are first
of all monitoring and metrics which help
us figure out whether or not our code is
broken at all and logging in error
reporting which help us figure out where
and why our code is broken so for
example with logging an error reporting
these are pretty straightforward logging
is kind of a plug-and-play it just
stores and indexes logs from your
function error reporting is also fairly
plug-and-play it's based off of logs and
gates logs into meaningful error reports
as you can see on the right so I know
that the font might be a little bit
small so I'll try to narrow it through
what's going on here on the Left we have
a sample log entry which essentially
says there is an error uninitialized
email address right now this is enough
in some cloud function called as well
see on the right it's called on new
message so the on the right we have
stats about how frequently this error
has occurred it was first seen 13 days
ago it was last seen six days ago it's
occurred 152 times we have a sample
stack trace and a histogram so this is a
useful command center for triaging any
errors that you might have now as far as
monitoring and metrics go they are not
as plug-and-play
but they are just as if not more useful
than logging in error reporting so
generally speaking stack drivers
monitoring and metrics tools help us
detect production bugs quickly they will
not necessarily guarantee that you will
detect production bugs but they will
increase your chances of detecting them
in a timely manner so our goal with this
configuration is to catch as many errors
as we can with the least setup possible
so the pros of this can of the
configuration that we're about to talk
about are that it's easy to set up it
determines if production is broken and
it can test any function type so the
cons are that it depends on logging
statement coverage so you need to
basically anytime there's an error you
need to make sure you're logging it and
it's not always helpful for identifying
the root causes of why things go wrong
or even where things go wrong so these
sort of decent configuration that you
can use this is like the first line of
defense if you will against bugs and
prod is to send out an alert if severe
log entries for example errors are too
frequent maybe more than 1% of
invocations or more than some constant
or something like that the better option
if you have the time and sort of the
engineer bandwidth is to send out an
alert if 'function execution time and
count exceed normal limits
and note that when I say better I
recommend employing both of these
there's no harm in having additional
metrics
if you have to pick one or the other
it's probably better if you go with the
the first one then the second one but
having both is ideal and some additional
checks you can do if you're working
primarily with HTTP triggered functions
or likewise HTTP triggered functions you
could just use stack drivers uptime
checks to check those URLs and make sure
those functions are responding with the
correct the correct status code so
things like you know 200 or 300 or so on
and so forth so without further ado
we're gonna do a quick demo a stack
driver monitoring and notice I kicked
off whoops I kicked off this command
earlier oops it's not showing up but I
kicked off command earlier that was an
Apache bench command that sense sent
10,000 requests to that cloud function
that I specified earlier now so if we
look at our stack diver page which is
here I'll refresh it so we notice that
there was a resolved in incident that
was declared today at about 1055 am so
this was an alert we got if we look at
the actual sort of inbox here we got a
sec driver alert and this was sent to us
at 10:55 today so it's telling us that
our metric threshold for this cloud
function was sort of violated and it's
above our threshold of 5 with a value of
thirty seven point three eight three so
what this is telling us is you said send
me an alert if more than five executions
were happening concurrently we had 37 so
if you got something like this you'd
probably want to say okay well what's
going wrong with this function is it
just suddenly super popular is there
some is that some like retry loop it's
some you know API calling it like way
too many times like what's going on here
and of course once you get this email
then you can follow up and investigate
as appropriate
so now that we've talked about all this
stuff we can kind of recap what we've
learned today
so as kind of a background of how all
this works or rather we've given a
background of how all this works and
talked about sort of an overview of
testing strategies in general then we
talked a little bit about sort of
applying that to the world of service
finally we talked about CICE pipelines
how to automate this testing on an
ongoing basis and then a little bit
about what to do when despite our best
efforts a bug gets out of gets out of
our canary or whatever in production and
we need to do something to detect that
bug quickly and resolve it before
ideally before our customers notice so
the key points that I would like people
to take away from this presentation if
there's a slide where you want to take a
photo this is it
so narrating through this basically
testing helps detect bugs and other
issues on an ongoing basis so testing is
effectively an insurance policy against
potential bugs and you know if your
managers ever asked well why should we
write tests the answer is they they not
only stop those potential bugs but they
stop the business impact of those
potential bugs note that also there are
many testing options out there that we
reviewed unit tests function tests
system tests so on and so forth or
integration test system tests and so
forth
and they all have different trade-offs
in terms of accuracy breath speed and
cost um
generally speaking we recommend that
uncritical reused or unmaintained code
you have lots of tests with a variety of
different scopes so you're gonna have a
lot of unit to us you're gonna have a
lot of system tests you're gonna have a
lot of integration tests may be several
static tests so on and so forth on less
important temporary or well maintained
code you can usually get away with fewer
higher-level tests because generally
speaking if your code is well-maintained
and you know there's a bug you can go in
and triage it pretty quickly but if you
don't know there's a bug then there's a
problem because you you if you don't
know that the problem exists you can't
address it right so that's why those
higher-level tests are important to say
well
does my code work at all and if my code
works from end to end then I'm
reasonably confident that there isn't
going to be a bug in it but if the
system tests fail then you can say okay
well something's broken I don't know
what but at least I can go deeper and
take a look at it and figure out what
went wrong
now the third the third takeaway here is
that stackdriver increases your chances
of deduct detecting production bugs
quickly emphasis on increases your
chances there is no guarantee you will
detect them within a certain amount of
time but it's easier to detect them and
more likely that you will detect them if
stackdriver is present the broad
configuration is to check for like
abnormal error rates and execution times
it's pretty easy to set up again like it
would probably take a developer maybe
about an hour to at most and finally
note that tests must address cloud
specific challenges so the challenge of
eventual consistency you can address
that using either timeouts or
exponential back-off and then the
challenge of shared resources you can
address this by using temporary test
environments or temporary test resources
like we did with that UUID function and
the system tests sample so I'd like to
thank you for coming to next today and
coming to my talk if you have any
questions feel free to email me at fast
at Google comm that is the word fast
with two A's otherwise I'll be hanging
around the server list demo booths so
you're welcome to come and speak to me
there Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]